you may recall the documentary called
supersized me it was about eating
McDonald's full-time and inspired one
man in Nashville called Kevin McGinnis
he's hoping the McDonald's diet will
Super downsize his body he's eating only
McDonald's for a hundred days to lose
weight and he reports back it's quote
absolutely working Kevin McGinnis blogs
about his diet He's a brave man he joins
us now Kevin thanks so much for coming
on so
by the way you look fit and vigorous I
will say in a non-creepy way but how are
you doing so how are you how are you
keeping fit on McDonald's what are you
doing
so literally the concept I was a boxer I
wrestling school and you have to cut you
have to cut to make weight so cutting
the calories cutting the food in half if
I ate three meals a day but I cut them
in half and I seek the heat before I eat
meaning I wait until that that heat in
your stomach that says you're hungry
everyone else calls it hunger I call it
my incinerator turning on to get rid of
all the excess and also burn off some of
the fat off my body and then I'll have
that next meal no meat no eating hours
no counting no measuring just cut the
meals in half eat three of them a day
when you're hungry and my belief is will
be 50 pounds down by the end of the
Hundred Days better blood work and
Better Health if you don't believe me to
follow along let's find out that's some
that's just so so really the essential
ingredient is self-control you're
approaching McDonald's in the way that I
never have which is with restraint so
like how do you handle how do you handle
breakfast
um
yeah well so breakfast is go to the
McDonald's order any breakfast menu item
so that I order the meal including a
dessert right if you don't have the
pastry whatever but then cutting in half
and at first so the first three or four
days wrap up the other half get it out
of sight out of mind and just eat the
half and then save the other half till
later eat that for lunch or save it for
the next day's breakfast whatever and
then just eat again each meal only half
of whatever that whole meal would be at
McDonald's cut it in half save the other
half after you've done it for about
three or four days your stomach will
have shrunk a little bit and then you
can just eat the half and you can wrap
up the other half after you've eaten
half of it either way is fine
two questions are you worried this will
kill you is the obvious one and second
how does McDonald's leftovers taste the
next day
so on the leftovers I'll answer that one
first definitely putting the sandwich in
the microwave with a little cup of water
so it actually steams a little bit
really good for the sandwiches for me I
like the softer you can put the whole
thing in an air fryer for the fries and
hash browns either air fryer or a dry
Skillet and it turns them right back to
almost brand new again so they're really
good as far as is it going to kill me
did the blood work at the beginning
we'll do blood work throughout my belief
is that it's going to absolutely improve
the blood work throughout the whole
process because by waiting go ahead
no that that's it you're a wrestler
obviously you're an Iron Man a brave Man
Too Kevin McGinnis thank you for joining
we'll be right back subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight